today the mat wall show a leftist media
personality says that she wants to be
referred to as a woman not a person with
a uterus now she finds herself the
target of the same leftist rage mob that
she has so often been a part of herself
a tale is all this time also the White
House condemns Uganda for its law
Banning homosexuality Billy Porter in
the view come up with the dumbest
defense of child drag shows though
they're all dumb of course CNN's Chief
climate alarmist issues a dire warning
for the planet and Gisele Bundchen
explains why her pursuit of authenticity
meant that she had to divorce Tom Brady
all of that and more today on the Matt
Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
according to a recent poll almost
two-thirds of Americans do not have a
will death is not something anyone likes
to think about but it's important to
plan for the future and ensure that your
loved ones are taken care of after you
pass away whether you're a first-time
parent early in your career or an empty
nester it is never too early or too late
to write your will and with epic will
you can get it done in as little as five
minutes for just 119 have you ever
considered who will care for your kids
when you pass away
how about you who will speak on your
behalf should you ever find yourself in
a situation where you're unable to make
health related decisions for yourself
who do you trust to handle your
financial obligations if you can't all
these questions can be some of the
hardest questions we face in life and
epic will is here to help you through
every step of the process epic Will's
team of estate planning attorneys has
done all the legal leg work so that you
don't have to
all you have to do is fill out their
step-by-step form and they'll help you
create your last will and testament
living will health care and financial
power of attorney all that can be done
don't put it off any longer two-thirds
of Americans do not have a will choose
to be in the smarter third of Americans
who do go to epicwell.com Walsh to save
10 on Epic Will's complete will package
that's epicwill.com Welsh
well we have grown accustomed to the
site of deranged Pitchfork mobs
descending upon someone and ripping them
to shreds uh for you know engaging in
the crime of wrong think but this
Feeding Frenzy this orgy of outrage
always takes on added intensity when the
target is a member of the mob itself as
we learn there is no fury like a
pitchfork mob scorned by one of its own
and we learned this lesson yet again
yesterday when leftist internet
personality Anna kasparian of The Young
Turks had a very brief moment of sanity
and there is nothing the left punishes
quicker or more severely than sanity so
kasparian tweeted this uh yesterday
afternoon she said I'm a woman please
don't ever refer to me as a person with
a uterus a birthing person or person who
menstruates how do people not realize
how degrading this is you can support
the transgender Community without doing
this
now every once in a while Anna will
engage in these flirtations with common
sense the relationship never goes
anywhere there's no commitment ever made
uh they never have a first date even but
she'll bet her eyes at Common Sense from
across the room and maybe wave in its
general direction
and sometimes her own side will let her
get away with it they'll forgive uh and
look the other way and forget about
these you know dalliances but not on
this issue because if there's one
absolutely unbending unyielding rule on
the left is that you may never say
anything even vaguely sensible on the
subject of gender I mean really you
can't say anything vaguely sensible on
any subject but in particular on this
subject and so it was inevitable that
Anna would wind up trending on Twitter
which she did because thousands of
leftist hyenas were pouncing on her
which they did here's just a very quick
survey of of the responses she receives
so I'll review read through just a few
of them
oh not you too I had I had real hopes
for this one what a shame you've fallen
for the faux outrage another one says I
prefer my feminism to include everyone
my Womanhood isn't threatened by the
existence of non-binary or trans people
why is yours
another says actually I actually thought
you were one of the good ones but
clearly I was wrong buying into the
transphobic hysteria and spreading more
ignorance and hate to a minority going
through absolute hell right now shameful
another says as a person without a
uterus I am so offended by this be
grateful you have one Anna or give it to
someone else
another says Anna that might be one of
the most Turf things you could ever say
just saying
another this is a crazy thing to tweet
right now person with a uterus is a term
used to include trans men who are not
women in conversations about things like
menstruation and pregnancy I can't
imagine what compelled you to tweak this
but you need to take it down
another says unblocking you to tell you
you're a piece of for joining this
transphobic Mass hysteria while being
silent about anti-trans legislation how
does a very small niche of people using
terms like birthing person to include
trans men and non-binary people
invalidate you get a grip
another says it's degrading to refer to
me as a person as a silly take and using
the necessary language to include and
support trans men in legislation and
medicine is in fact necessary to
supporting the trans community
another says I'm a person who menstrates
who has a uterus into his head to flee
my state to have an abortion I'm not a
woman and excluding trans people like me
from the conversation further
marginalizes us it hurts no one to be
inclusive and then I'm so sick of CIS
people I can count the ones I trust on
one hand how do CIS people keep making
our genocide about their feelings and
yes I am subtweeting Anna kasparian and
her heel turned
and then finally oh with this stupid
made-up trans folks are having their
existence criminalized in state after
State and you want to whine about this
in other words
the left wasn't happy not that they're
ever happy about anything really and in
a certain way you can sort of understand
why they felt betrayed after all this is
Anna kasparin of The Young Turks star of
such YouTube videos as Hill hosts
obliterates transphobic co-hosts on dead
naming trans people and insane
Republican monsters are trying to
destroy the trans community
and then JK Rowling is being transphobic
again
in fact just for fun let's take a brief
listen to that last clip about uh JK
Rowling here it is
JK Rowling is in the hot seat yet again
for weighing in on transgender issues
this time in the context of um
rape and how some countries have decided
to honor uh the gender identity of
people who are transgendered now she
tweeted this war is peace freedom is
slavery ignorance is strength the
penised individual who raped you is a
woman the paranoia is in fact stemming
from a recent law in Scotland which
allows trans people to self-identify as
male or female in the Scottish census
even if it differs from their uh their
gender at Birth now police have been
criticized for saying they will record
rapes by offenders with male genitalia
is being committed by a woman if the
attacker identifies as a female even if
they have not legally changed their
gender so apparently this is what has
gotten her very upset and I just
I just
I don't I don't I don't get it
she doesn't get it she just doesn't get
it she doesn't get why JK Rowling
wouldn't want male rapists to be housed
in female prisons she doesn't get it she
doesn't get why JK Rowling believes that
male rapists are men and should be
housed with men no matter how they
self-identify
she doesn't get it but she doesn't get
it but she's sure that JK Rowling is
being transphobic right whatever's going
on it's definitely that indeed everyone
on the right uh on the right or rather
to the right of her because straight
into the JK Rowling's not on the right
everyone to the right of her on this
issue is transphobic she has made that
very clear many times calling people
transphobic is one of her favorite
pastimes
and now the transphobic shoe is on the
other foot
so let me see if I can break this down a
little bit and help Anna understand
what's happening to her let me see if I
can mansplain this a little bit and I
know she watches a lot of my content so
I'm sure that she'll see this and uh and
perhaps respond by calling me a
transphob as is her custom
so here's the issue Anna
I'm gonna completely skip past the fact
that you have yourself for years
contributed to this rabid mob mentality
which treats any deviation from gender
ideology Doctrine as a genocidal
transphobia okay the people attacking
you today are responding exactly as you
have responded to so many others and
exactly as you have encouraged people to
respond
yes it is annoying isn't it when a
completely reasonable statement is met
with these kinds of histrionics it's
frustrating when people label your
argument you know call it bigoted call
it transphobic and believe that simply
labeling it can be a substitute for
actually engaging with it
I know it's frustrating happens to me
all the time happens to me by you in
fact so yes this is a dose of your own
medicine and it's a bitter medicine
indeed but we aren't going to harp on
that instead I want to make a point that
um
will be more useful to you and to
everyone listening to this
you say that we can support the
transgender Community quote unquote
without engaging in the silly word games
that you're you know rightly objecting
to
but you're wrong about that Anna we
cannot support the transgender Community
without doing those things we can't
okay you cannot reject a label like a
person with a uterus while still
supporting the trans Community you can't
and I'll tell you why two reasons first
trans activists have set the terms for
what qualifies as support
those terms are quite clear and I know
you're well aware of them
support for the trans community means
affirmation and affirmation means
literally to State as a fact to assert
strongly and publicly to uphold and
defend
and this is just about the only word
that these people ever use according to
its dictionary definition in the case of
this one single word affirmation
they do mean it exactly as the
dictionary defines it
to support them means to affirm them and
to affirm that means to loudly and
publicly uphold whatever assertions they
make about themselves and about the
world and um and it also means asserting
their self-perception as fact
there is no other version of support
that they will accept
and so it's incoherent even oxymoronic
for you to say I disagree with trans
activists on this point but I support
them because you can't support them and
disagree with them at the same time they
won't allow it they won't allow it they
demand total and absolute Conformity
that is the rule and it is a rule that
again
you yourself have enforced many times
second
you do support
um the reality of transgenders a meaning
that you believe that transgender is a
legitimate category of being and that it
really is possible for a person to be
trans that is a person can exist beyond
the binary of male and female you
believe this uh you support that idea
and that's what you mean when you say
that you support the trans Community but
if you believe that Anna then you you
have already reduced yourself to a mere
person with a uterus the whole point of
these terms is that according to gender
ideology you are simply an assemblage of
body parts and that assemblage has no
special meaning or significance and does
not point to any identity in particular
you are a woman who just so happens to
have female reproductive parts okay and
there are many other women who are just
as womanly as you and whose Womanhood is
just as valid as yours but who do not
have any of those parts
a man who started identifying as a woman
yesterday afternoon is just as much a
woman as you the only difference is your
uterus and your other anatomical
features which are totally meaningless
this is the doctrine of gender ideology
you either accept it or you don't
but you cannot accept it you cannot
affirm this theory of reality and then
try to quibble around the edges about
the terminology especially because the
terminology makes sense it is entirely
valid if
gender ideology Central claims are true
okay if gender ideology Central claims
are true
then everything else they say really
follows from that premise
and you believe that those Central
claims are true
or at least you say you believe it
see there's no middle ground here and I
I know you want to find one but it
doesn't exist if you want to be a woman
and if you want that word to mean
something
then Rachel Levine cannot be a woman and
Dylan Mulvaney cannot be a woman and
Leah Thomas cannot be a woman and
Caitlyn Jenner cannot be a woman
okay Womanhood ain't big enough for both
of you
it's one of the other
if they are women and you are a woman
then the word doesn't mean anything and
the identity doesn't mean anything in
which case we probably should stop using
it and just start calling you a vagina
Haver
because that's all you would be that and
nothing more
now if you don't like that
if you don't want that
then you must free yourself and Free
Your Mind
from the mental slavery of gender
ideology you must reject it totally in
every facet it does not leave you any
other choice
it doesn't intend to leave you any other
choice
so
renounce that Madness and come to this
side join the transphobes as you have
called us so many times
we will accept your apology and welcome
you as a prodigal son or daughter in
your case because we actually know the
difference
or you can flee back into the arms of
maniacs
who believe in pregnant men and think
that child castration is a valid Medical
Practice
those are your two options there are no
others
the choice is yours
and I think I know which one you'll make
but hopes brings a turtle and the truth
beckons to us all
now let's get to our five headlines
don't fall for all those free phone
deals from Verizon at T or T-Mobile it's
just another trick to lock you into a
long-term contract that could cost you a
fortune every month instead get a brand
new iPhone 12 from Pure Talk for just 12
a month with pure talk there is no
contract no interest you can cancel or
leave at any time Pure Talk uses the
same Nationwide networks as major
carriers you'll get the same reliable
coverage you're used to with a range of
affordable plans to choose from you can
find the perfect option for your needs
get unlimited talk text and plenty of
data for just thirty dollars a month
switch over to Pure Talk in as little as
10 minutes while keeping your phone and
your phone number their us-based
customer service team makes the switch
really easy Pure Talk is so sure you're
going to love your service they're
backing it up with a 100 money back
guarantee go to puretalk.com enter promo
code Walsh to save 50 off your first
month that's puretalk.com promo code
walls puretalk is simply smarter
Wireless
okay uh headline from CNN and this is a
headline it's been repeated by many
other mainstream Outlets yeah and and
and uh phrased framed almost exactly
this way
Uganda Parliament passes Bill
criminalizing identifying as lgbtq
imposes death penalty for some offenses
the article says Ugandan lawmakers on
Tuesday approved some of the world's
harshest anti-gay laws making some
crimes punishable punishable by death
and imposing up to 20 years in prison
for people identifying as lgbtq
sorry lgbtq plus the new legislation
constitutes a further Crackdown on lgbtq
plus people in a country where same-sex
relations were already illegal
punishable by life imprisonment it
targets an array of activities that
includes a ban on promoting and abetting
homosexuality as well as conspiracy to
engage in homosexuality Reuters reported
according to the bill the death penalty
may be invoked for cases involving
aggravated homosexuality a broad term
used in legislation to describe sex acts
committed without consent or under
duress against children people with
mental or physical disabilities by a
Serial offender offender or involving
incest
so um
in other words rape okay sex acts
committed without consent otherwise
known as rape and so when you hear in
the headlines that they're imposing the
death penalty for homosexual acts
um
that's true
but well they don't often mention in the
headlines and they make you read down
several paragraphs before they get to
get to it is that is specifically it's
the death penalty for rape okay for the
for rape for child molestation
um for raping a disabled person
that's what they're imposing the death
penalty for
um
all right continues uh a person who
commits the offense of aggravated
homosexuality and is liable on
conviction to suffer death reads the
Amendments which were presented by the
chairperson uh for legal and
parliamentary Affairs Robina ruwakuju
I think I actually probably pronounced
that correctly or wakuju
um it's always a problem for me when a
country like Uganda is in the news
because now I'm reading uh articles with
lots of Ugandan names and it doesn't
always work out well for me opposition
lawmaker yusaman uh
baselerwa introduced the
anti-homosexuality bill 2023 to
Parliament saying it aims to protect our
church culture the legal religious and
traditional family values of ugandans
from the acts that are likely to promote
sexual promiscuity in this country the
objective of the bill was to establish a
comprehensive and enhanced legislation
to protect traditional Family Values our
diverse culture our faiths by
prohibiting any form of sexual relations
between persons of the same sex and the
promotion or recognition of sexual
relations between persons of the same
sex
uh this is what this lawmaker said on
Tuesday
so that's the bill that's what they're
doing in Uganda and um
you might ask yourself well uh what
business is it of ours what laws they're
passing in Uganda
well the cultural colonialists in this
country who are the Democrats are not
happy about it and they believe that
it's very much our business what laws
they pass in Uganda
um we already heard from the Pentagon
yesterday about how LGBT rights are a
core part of our foreign policy and now
here here is a Karen Jean pair at the
White House
um flushing that out a little bit and
condemning Uganda for this anti-gay law
she says continue
we have grave concerns with the passage
of the anti-homosexuality ACT aha by the
parliament of Uganda yesterday an
increasing violence targeting lgbtqi
plus persons if the AHA is signed into
law and enacted it would impinge upon
Universal human rights jeopardize
progress in the fight against HIV AIDS
deter tourism and invest in Uganda and
damage uganda's International reputation
the bill is one of the most extreme
anti-lgbtqi plus laws in the world
human rights are Universal no one should
be attacked imprisoned or killed simply
because of who they are or whom they
love
um
yes I'm sure this is a threat that means
a lot to Uganda
if you pass this bill it will damage
your International reputation I'm sure
Uganda is very concerned about that and
there's been a lot of talk like this
from the Democrats in the White House
and again this is not just about Uganda
as they've made it clear this is why
they you know hang Pride flags from all
the embassies and everything else that
this is a that's spreading LGBT rights
just as they used to be concerned with
spreading democracy and they still are
allegedly concerned about that but now
we're adding you know it's what does
that mean so it's like we're spreading
demo we're spreading a way of life we're
spreading democracy but what does that
mean well that's the meaning of that
concept and that agenda has changed
slightly over the years
um
not that it was ever a good idea to go
around trying to spread a way of life in
countries that aren't interested in it
but now that you know a central part of
that is LGBT rights because as far as
the powers that be are concerned this is
like the most important part of being a
of being a you know a country in a
democracy is protecting so-called LGBT
rights
um
so this is just something to keep in
mind
whenever you hear anyone on the left
um
condemn colonialism
and talk about the dangers of
colonialism
and how dare you know a white Western
countries go into other countries and
try to tell them how to live
there still is colonialism happening in
our world today
but it's almost entirely at least when
it comes to to Western countries it's
almost entirely by the left
okay because everything that they say in
condemning colonialism and being
anti-colonialist all of that is total
nonsense
uh because
they in fact believe
that every country in the world should
conform to their value system
and they don't think that Uganda has any
particular right to govern itself and uh
and have its own culture in its own way
of life
so this is this is that's what you're
saying there
also somebody keep in mind whenever you
hear them talk about multiculturalism
and how they really believe in
multiculturalism and they and it's so
important to to accept other cultures
and celebrate other cultures I mean that
is that could not be more false coming
from them
celebrate all the cultures that's the
last thing they'd ever want to do
no what what they mean is that they want
people from other cultures and they want
people who look different they want they
want a lot of uh people of different
skin colors and shades and different
ethnic backgrounds uh they want to bring
all of them together
Under the Umbrella of leftism
that's what they mean by
multiculturalism as I always say it's it
for them diversity multiculturalism
their ultimate you know kind of vision
of diversity and multiculturalism is uh
you know a whole bunch of people who
look different
speaking in unison and saying the same
things
that's what they mean
because if you're really going to
celebrate other cultures well
um that's what this is
okay in fact this this is
Uganda is not an outlier
many cultures outside of the western
world
are not at all accepting of um
you know
of our ideas of uh of of uh
sexual morality and all the rest of it
our ideas of it they they have very
different ideas about that
and it is in fact it's not just one
aspect of their culture it is a core
part of their culture
and if you can't accept that then then
you you're not interested in in
accepting other cultures
um
you are a colonialist
who believes that we in the west know
the right way to live and we have the
correct value systems and everyone else
should adopt it that's what you believe
and if that is what you believe then at
least admit it just come out and say it
and then we could start from an honest
you know
playing field
we'd start on honest footing at least
where everybody is saying what they
actually believe
all right the Daily Mail has this
Nebraska's politicians started debating
a bill on Tuesday to ban surgery for
transgender children and young adults
after an opponent of the bill spent
three weeks blocking a vote with a
filibuster Michaela Kavanaugh a Democrat
representing an Omaha District in the
state senate launched her obstruction
after Kathleen kauth a republican also
representing Omaha introduced the bill
the bill was introduced on January 17th
and would forbid gender affirming care
so security blockers hormone therapy and
surgeries for those under 19.
Kavanaugh and her supporters said that
the bill was harmful to transgender
teenagers calling it genocide and vowing
to slow legislation to halt in protest I
think we have the clip of her ranting
about genocide here it is
I want
us to have the debate
on these bills
and I want us to take a vote on these
bills
I want a record for the history of this
genocide
for those who stood by it for those who
had an opportunity
to change the course of history the
direction in which we are moving as a
state and as a country I want a record
I want the bloody hands recorded
this is a genocide
this is an assault on a population of
people
because they are different
from you
uh I totally agree
with at least the first part of that
very much disagree with the second part
about how this is a genocide okay
um to believe that
refraining from castrating uh children
is a genocide to believe that if you
actually believe that then then you are
in fact psychotic you are you are a
psychotic person who you should be in an
asylum somewhere if you really believe
that
you are not fit if you actually believe
that it is genocidal to not castrate and
sterilize a child then you should be in
a straight jacket locked in a padded
room somewhere you are not fit to live
in human society you are not fit to live
outside of the outside of an insane
asylum
um I I wouldn't
I
I wouldn't want to live next day I
wouldn't trust you I wouldn't want to
live in the same neighborhood as you I
wouldn't trust my children around you
uh you are a dangerous lunatic if you
actually believe that now
I don't think that most of these people
actually believe that
um I think that they know that it's
crazy but they say it anyway
uh because it's uh it's a it's a talking
point
which doesn't make it much better
it doesn't make it much better in fact
if anything it makes it worse
so I don't agree with that part because
I am not a you know a a psychotic
lunatic
um
but the first part she says I want a
record there should be a record of where
people stand on this I totally agree
I want it on the record too
I want it on the record
um every single person
who uh
endorsed this idea that we should
sterilize and castrate children who
endorse the idea that men can get
pregnant uh that women have penises and
all the rest of it I want I want a
record of all of that
um so that historians in the future can
look back
and and they can know who the culprits
were
and who it was that who was responsible
for introducing this madness into
society and promoting it
because historians are going to they are
they are going to spend
centuries
uh trying to unravel this mystery
about how exactly this madness gripped a
hold of uh
of American society in the early 2000s
how did it happen
and what was the the agenda behind it
and did they really believe that stuff
how many people believed it they're
gonna their historians are gonna spend
Century it's gonna be a mystery
okay this is so you have to understand
we are living through right now what
will later be considered a historical
mystery
um
you know that's that's the category this
is going to belong to
this is going to be like Roanoke you
know uh the the when all the villagers
disappear and no one knows where they
are and it's for centuries afterwards
people try to figure out what happened
uh well it's a similar sort of thing
except it's that common sense and Sanity
just disappeared from society
at least from historical figure that's
what it's going to seem like it's going
to seem like out of nowhere it just
evaporated
and there was this incident of mass
hysteria and lunacy
and so uh the culprits and the people
responsible for that I want them on the
record and I want them known
because all of you people are going to
be
um
your names are are going to be
anathema for all of time I mean you are
going to be disgraced
by the history books for all of time
speaking of people who are a disgrace is
the view had Billy Porter on and Billy
Porter I've never we'd never quite
speaking I guess it's also maybe a
historic mystery that will have to be
unraveled but
um how did this guy ever become a thing
I I it's not exactly clear other than
the fact that he's black and
flamboyantly homosexual and so I guess
that explains it but that's all he's
really got going for him and uh he was
on The View talking about drag queens
and offering his defense of it let's
watch
when you were here in July of 2022 yes
we talked about how Florida Governor uh
DeSantis uh had just filed a complaint
against a bar called the r house that
holds drag shows okay eight months later
things have only escalated as we talk
about it you know it's constant um
aggravation with this what do you make
of the fact that we're still talking
about this and that um it's happening in
other states too not just Florida yeah
it's there's this war against trans
people which is an lgbtq plus people and
people who are othered and Cabaret being
Cabaret people it's a it's a circle of
life yeah you know why are they doing it
for power yeah everything is about power
and you could always trace it back to
the money you say that all the time
it's follow the money follow the power
power at any cost it's very hypocritical
you know the the leading cause of death
in children
[Applause]
you know and it just it's a distraction
it's a distraction on purpose we don't
know what to pay we don't know what to
pay attention to you know our justice
system is convoluted it's hard to
understand on purpose let's be clear
about that it's on purpose you know it
was like when we were talking when we
were talking about Roe v Wade that the
word codified came up I was like what is
and y'all didn't do I didn't do it 50
years what
what's happening yeah you know subpoenas
if any one of us is subpoenaed we and if
we don't go we end up in jail right a
little purple what's happening that's
the question we all have when we look at
this guy
um so a couple things here
first of all I like how Cabaret people
that that's been added into the list
that's been added into the list of uh
there's a war on Cabaret people is that
is that now a cap is that a category of
identity that we're so we would put that
in the LGBT uh alphabet soup
Cabaret people
he says the leading cause of death among
children is um are guns
and that's not even close to true
not even close
okay the guns don't even
um they are a fraction of what is the
actual leading cause of death among
children that would be abortion
okay that's hundreds of thousands of
children killed every year through
abortion
so not even close
guns are a distant distant second place
I mean the whole thing is a is obviously
a ridiculous straw man red herring I
mean uh no no one is being killed by
drag queens no one ever said that they
are
okay but so is that the standard is
anything's okay for children as long as
it doesn't directly kill them
so whatever it is as long as they are
killed by it on the spot it's okay
well these people they they cannot
defend any of their positions because
their positions are horrifying insane
nonsense and they know they can't defend
it and so the straw man is all they have
they have to constantly argue against
um points that no one is making
Jon Stewart did the same thing it was a
big gotcha moment he was interviewing
someone a couple weeks ago
hey drag queens aren't killing anyone
yeah who said they are that's not the
point you that's not what we're
saying
we are
um proposing this this radical idea that
there can be things that are bad for
kids even if they aren't killed by it
okay there's there's like things that
are good for children and then there are
things that kill children
but there's a lot of room in between
those two things
it's not as though well as long as it's
not here and killing them then it's
automatically good
do we really need to explain this to you
clowns do you need this explained to you
we always come back to the same question
of are you as stupid and crazy as you
are pretending to be
you just always assume that you're not
but maybe maybe my assumption was wrong
and then we hear that it's about the
money and power this is all about money
and power
what money is there in in telling drag
queens that they can't strip for little
kids
okay when we tell you that you're not
allowed to uh cross-dress and perform
sexually for children you think we make
money on that
we make money on you not sexually
um you know sexually harassing children
which is what
you know which which is what dancing in
drag for child that's what it is
um so you think
you think we might how do we monetize
that how do we monetize you not doing
that
power like what additional power yeah I
mean if we if we stop you from
sexualizing children then and we're able
to successfully stop you then that is
exerting power I suppose but this is not
this is power that we would never want
to have to exert because it shouldn't
come up in the first place
but no there's no money in it
the money is always is on that side
and that's the case for all these things
if you notice that there's a the
financial incentive is on the other side
okay
um
there is millions and millions and
millions of dollars at stake in the
gender transition industry
that is a
multi-multi-multi-million dollar
industry
uh and you've got pharmaceutical
companies wrapped up into it medical
industry hospitals clinics doctors
nurses therapists counselors
psychologists psychiatrists all these
people okay and that's not even to
mention the professional activists and
the advocacy groups or the all these
people uh not even mentioning that but
but if you bring all that together
you've got tons of money
that they're making on this
um and if this stuff is outlawed and if
we're outlawing the transit of kids
it's not like the money goes to us now
it's not like those are millions of
dollars go to us it's just they're not
getting spent they go away no one makes
them
okay there is not in fact a
multi-million dollar industry of
stopping kids from being castrated that
industry doesn't exist
same thing with abortion as he mentioned
where's all the big money there
abortion is a billion dollar industry
okay a billion dollar industry is
abortion
because they charge money
goes in pays someone you oftentimes a
man this is female empowerment I'm gonna
pay a man to kill my child
because I'm an empowered woman
lots of money on that
it's also self-serving
can people defend the right to an
abortion for their own convenience and
for their own lifestyle and they'll tell
you that it's it's they're very open
about it
pro-lifers on the other hand we don't
make any money off of this
okay we don't make money off of you not
getting an abortion
and we also don't benefit from it
directly
we don't directly benefit from you not
killing your child
we're speaking up for the child we don't
we don't benefit from that
um
I mean the most you yeah there are there
are crisis pregnancy centers out there
Pregnancy Resource Centers I'll tell you
something the people that are in that
business they're not wealthy okay
they're not making anywhere close to
what the abortion abortionists are
making
but even that if you want to if that's
the big Financial incentive so yeah
getting that really profitable business
of paying a of working at a Pregnancy
Resource Center you know real profitable
a lot of money to be made there I mean
we're talking hundreds of dollars
but even that little pittance I mean the
as we fight against the abortion
and uh if as we as we succeed in
mitigating abortions
um
then I mean it's kind of like the goal
of a pro-lifer is to make yourself and
to make this movement
unnecessary
to make it irrelevant that's our goal
while on the other side they are
clinging to relevance and profit margins
and all the rest of it and that's the
again that's the case down the line on
nearly all these issues
all right a couple other quick uh Clips
to play here's CNN's Chief climate
alarmist here to tell us that climate
alarmism doesn't actually exist
just into CNN a dire warning about the
state of the planet the new U.N report
warns the climate Time Bomb is ticking
and the world is running out of time to
avoid catastrophe so that assessment
comes from the world's most
authoritative body on climate change
which says the Earth is going to pass
this critical warning threshold now much
earlier than expected I mean we're
tearing it down they're talking about
the early 2030s CNN Chief climate
correspondent Bill Ware is here so um
please tell me we can stop this bill oh
I'd love to tell you that we have to
believe that and we can and that really
the takeaway is that the tools in our
hands there are no Miracles needed when
it comes to technology it's all right
here it's all about political will but
let me explain the context here every
year thousands of peer-reviewed papers
around the world look at the ice or the
clouds or the Penguins or every little
aspect of our changing Planet the ipcc
these are scientists from 195 countries
have to synthesize all that information
their governments have to approve the
language and then they put this report
together and give it to lawmakers in
time for this next cup that's coming up
in in the United Arab Emirates and it is
the most unequivocal there's no such
thing as climate alarmism anymore the
the time bomb is ticking but we have the
guide on how to Defuse The Bomb right in
our hands right here
the time bomb we've been hearing about
this ticking Time Bomb for a long time
and uh
but you know most and you imagine the uh
maybe the old-fashioned cartoon time
bomb with the long Wick that's you know
that's it's going down it's going to
explode
um or maybe you imagine the the actual
digital timer on it you know we have to
find a way to diffuse it you have to cut
like the old 90s action flicks you gotta
someone's gotta cut the red wire and the
blue wire
um but they keep extending the time
that's the interesting thing they keep
extending so it's about to go off it's
always just about to go off and then
we're all going to be dead I will say
you know
I I think if you're CNN CNN they've got
the chief climate reporter and he says
there's climate alarmism doesn't exist
so like because remember no matter what
you say about the climate whatever
alarming statements you make it's it's
true and so it's not alarmism that's the
point that he's trying to make
um
we really are on the verge of an
apocalypse nothing nothing alarmist
about it he claims
well I think
if that's the case
I mean really the most powerful
statement
and the most worthwhile thing that CNN
could do is to just shut down entirely
you think about all the carbon emissions
think about all the energy that is used
just to keep a cable news channel on the
air 24 7.
think about the carbon footprint
and if we're on the verge of of
planetary destruction because of this
then I think you have no choice morally
but the shutdown operations entirely and
that would be a statement
to the rest of the world I mean that if
you want to you want to say something
that's meaningful that would do it you
say we're going to shut down completely
because we can no longer contribute
to the coming apocalypse we are going I
want to hear from Don Lemon and all the
rest we're shutting down we're gonna go
live in the woods in caves and um we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna subsist on
on berries and and uh locusts like like
John the Baptist in the wilderness and
that's how we're going to live our lives
because we cannot contribute anymore
to the coming planetary extinction level
event
that would be a statement or maybe it
really wouldn't be a statement at all
because nobody would notice even if they
did that this is CNN that we're talking
about
finally sad news from the New York Post
rainbow-haired rapper Takashi 69 was
brutally beaten by a group of men inside
the bathroom of a Florida gym on Tuesday
the 26 year old musician in ex-con was
rushed to the hospital after he was
reportedly attacked inside the restroom
of an LA Fitness in Southern Florida and
there is um
there is uh video of this of him his
just being he's being brutally as it
says brutally beaten and stomped on and
uh but it's it's not clear what the
motivation is
but then it does note in the article he
was sentenced to two years in prison in
2019 for his role in the nine tray
Gangsta Bloods gang facing decades in
prison on racketeering and other charges
but took a plea deal that lowered his
time in exchange for helping the feds
take down his former Bloods Associates
and so he is a snitch and so it's uh
it's assumed that he was that that's why
he was beat up because he's a snitch
I think that that's not fair and I know
that I know that I'm biased because as
you know this is my guy Takashi 69 one
of the most brilliant uh musical artists
certainly of this Century easily but
really I think you know in Western uh
history
but it's on biased but also are we
really still doing this no snitching
thing
like this Honor Code among criminals
it only works if the criminals have some
sense of Honor but they don't this isn't
the mafia in the 1940s or whatever okay
these are not gentlemen criminals who
wear tuxedos uh that's that's not what
this is these are these are Savage
animals so
um so why not snitch in that case I mean
that's the argument I would be making if
I was takashi69 if I was in his shoes
that's the organizing I'd be saying look
guys
come on I mean we're we're all criminals
here we don't have any sense of we're in
it for ourselves
so come on like of course I'm gonna
snitch what am I going to go to prison
on principle what principle
I'm I'm the criminal just like you
that's the argument I would make
right before they stab me to death my
argument would boil down to come on guys
come on guys come on
and then they would cut my throat but at
least you know it's worth a try
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
castidy says The Little Mermaid
originally is a story about being
selfless yes told through a love story
but the whole point of it is about
sacrificing oneself for the one you love
twisting it into the idea of self-love
above all is truly inverted
um
yeah that's that's often one of the
central themes of uh these old fairy
tales but but really this this this
shift into making itself focused and
making it all about you know really the
moral at the end of the story is like a
self-help Maxim kind of thing uh this is
this is a uh a shift that has been
happening over that didn't just it
didn't just start now with Disney doing
these live-action remakes it's actually
been happening for decades I mean like I
said before you go back and you watch
those um cartoons in the 90s
whole lot better than what Disney puts
out now but even then you know a lot of
these politically correct themes and
they were already kind of neutering some
of these uh some of these deeper you
know more meaningful aspects of these
stories all right
native Irish says my daughter told me
she was trans and that I didn't give
birth to a girl I gave birth to a boy
and her name is dead she wants she talks
to me like trash and there's this is
nothing new uh she is and has always
done what she wants no matter what I say
she's now pregnant with my grandson and
has told me that I'm not allowed to see
him this has done irreversible damage to
my own mental health but has never
mattered to her because everything has
always been about her and no one's
feelings have ever mattered to her well
that's a terrible story I'm sorry you're
going through that I mean it also is
you know she says that she's she's not a
you didn't give birth to a girl
um she's not a woman
she's a boy and yet she's pregnant you
know this is the kind of incoherence
obviously that you see there
um
but it also doesn't
and this is the same story that we hear
from parents who've gone through this
that um
it's this intense selfishness on the
part of the child who's who's
uh doing the gender especially when it's
older you know to say child like an
adult who's going through this
transition quote unquote transition uh
there's just this intense selfishness
but that's part of
the ideology that is the whole ideology
that's the point
it's only about them it's only about
affirming them and your feelings you
know you exist
to affirm her
that's your whole purpose in life
that's what they believe and that's what
they've been taught and it's a just a
terrible thing
um
Laura says I feel all that this man
writes times two I completely blame the
therapist I haven't been blocked out of
one of my son's lives uh for almost two
years now it's so much worse than what
this man says he's being so very
restrained it's like losing my sons only
in a groundhog day nightmare that never
ends it's felt over and over again
uh
yeah that's that's why I I got in uh
people on the left were very upset I
mean they're upset about anything I say
but they were upset recently when I said
that um
for one thing I would rather it is a
fate worse than death for a parent
to have their child sucked into this
cult
and uh I feel quite confident in saying
that not only because I can imagine what
I would feel like if it happened to me
but I also hear from the testimonies of
people like yourself
that it is like it's it's like going
through the death of a child
and almost any parent would agree that
you know you would rather die than have
your child die any any loving parent
would agree and that's and that's what
this feels like in a very real life and
then it's made even worse because if
your child actually dies then it's a
terrible tragedy that you never you
never fully get over of course but
Society recognizes it as a tragedy
where in this case uh much of society
does not see as a tragedy in fact it's
the other way around they tell you that
you're supposed to celebrate this
and there's something wrong with you if
you won't
it's on top of the grief and the morning
it's also the guilt that they try to put
on you it's a really terrible
uh thing
uh let's see
uh let's see there's a couple
Harrison says lol this ensuing war
between Knowles and Walsh is amazing
Matt's desperate attempt to validate a
theory he clearly doesn't actually
believe in because he he boxed himself
into this with a series of sarcastic
jokes that now force him into this
contrived Devil's Advocate position is
hilarious it does show how intelligent
he is though as he on the spot defends
it very eloquently
well you're wrong if you think that I
don't actually believe this
yeah I I do totally unironically believe
that I mean it's one thing to talk about
the UFOs and have aliens visited here
before
um but if we're talking about do they
exist anywhere in the universe then I
absolutely do believe
Patrick says I'm with Michael after all
that Matt's argument is still just the
universe is so big he doesn't even
grapple with fermi's Paradox if the
universe is teeming with life why
haven't we seen any evidence of it yet
so well firm is paradox to me is is
absurd um I I don't see it as a paradox
at all
the idea is that the Universe if the
universe has other life in it then why
haven't we encountered it yet uh why
haven't we received a signal or a
visitation or an Alien Probe has come
back you know why haven't that why
hasn't that happened and because it
hasn't happened yet and yet supposedly
so much life universe it creates a
paradox that's the idea
but this is first of all built on the
assumption that there hasn't been a
signal or a visitation of some kind or
probe or anything and we don't actually
know if that's true or not but assuming
that we haven't had any kind of contact
there's no Paradox here because the
universe is in fact very very big and I
explained yesterday why the the size of
the universe is significant and how that
factors into this discussion
you can't debunk that argument by simply
scoffing at it
and the fact that you would you would
scoff at it only tells me you haven't
really considered just how vast the
universe is or what that means that's
one thing I'm learning from this
conversation and from the reaction from
the people it seems like
it's like everyone knows the universe is
really big right anyone will tell you
that but I think there are some people
who've never really thought about what
that means they they
um they've never tried and no one can
fully wrap their head around it because
this the distances are so large that you
can't even talk about them in a way
that's so coherent I think there's a lot
of people that have never really spent
any time thinking about that I'm weird
so I spend
lots of time I think about that every
day a day doesn't go by when I don't
Ponder like the vastness of the universe
it's just it's just something my mind
always goes back
um
I get and it's strange to me to think
that there are people who don't spend
any time thinking about that but I guess
they don't
because if you do think about it you
realize I mean think of it this way if
the universe is a country okay if you
think of the universe like a country
then each solar system is a neighborhood
and each Galaxy is a state you know by
analogy right okay
well the neighborhood closest to ours
the neighborhood that's like one block
over
close the solar system is 20 trillion
miles away
I mean the next closest house in our
neighborhood right next door is 100
million miles away and we've never been
there and we're years away from making
it there and when we do go there it'll
take years to get there that's just the
house next door we we've been to our
mailbox which is like the moon when we
last went there 50 years ago and that's
like we're not even sure if we can make
it back to the mailbox
the next the next neighborhood 20
trillion miles is how far away it is
um it would take tens of thousands of
years to get there even if we were
traveling at the speed of light it would
take four years to get there and we'd
all die of radiation poisoning on the
way and we can't travel to speed of
light anyway or even come close to it
so consider like the Voyager 1 space
probe okay it launched 45 years ago
um it's still not anywhere close
traveling 45 years
it's going like a million miles a day
not anywhere close to making it out of
our solar system there's this thing
called the Oort cloud which is this um
ring of ice and dust surrounding our uh
our our solar system and it's somewhat
like hypothetical because we don't
exactly know what it is or if it's even
there but the idea is it's the this ring
of kind of ice particles
um surrounding our sources Voyager space
probe has been going for 45 years it is
still 300 years away from making it to
the inner edge of the Oort cloud you
know how long it'll take to cross the
Oort cloud 30 000 years and then when it
makes it to the other end of the Oort it
still has another 40 000 years before it
makes it to the next star that's how big
everything is
um which just goes to show it like if
you don't understand why that makes it
so absurd to rule out the possibility of
other life or to assume that we must
have been visited by now
if you don't understand that I don't
know how else to explain it
it's very likely that this the distances
are so vast that it's impossible to
Traverse them it just can't happen and
no one ever will we could Advance as a
civilization for a million years without
destroying ourselves it probably
wouldn't happen because we would destroy
ourselves we could advance for a million
years
and we still wouldn't have a way of
making it out of the solar system
because maybe it's just not possible to
do
um
and even if it is possible uh it still
I've used so many different analogies
I'll settle on that one for right now
despite the lackluster economy the daily
wire is thriving and not only that we
are hiring we're currently looking for a
video editor to join our fast-growing
post-production team this person will
get the opportunity to work on a variety
of content including our daily podcasts
long form video interviews and videos
YouTube videos as well as shows like Ben
Shapiro's debunked documentaries from
Jordan Peterson and much more four plus
years of professional video editing
experience and familiarity and working
at a very fast pace uh in a fast-paced
environment with high turnaround times
is required bonus points for experience
working on viral YouTube content as well
this is the perfect role for someone who
can expertly follow standardized video
editing formats while also processing a
strong creative skill set a link to your
wheel is a required for consideration
the position is based in Nashville
Tennessee if you want more information
you can visit dailywire.com careers
that's dailywire.com careers today now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
Gisele Bundchen a supermodel and ex-wife
of Tom Brady is now speaking out
publicly about her divorce from the
former NFL star you might say with some
truth that it's a kind of cheap to use
this story as fodder for this segment
after all anytime a celebrity speaks
publicly about a divorce they're
guaranteed to say things worthy of
cancellation celebrities are very often
shallow self-absorbed and stupid and
never does that become more apparent
than when they are trying to publicly
rationalize their failed marriages be
that as it may cheap or not Gisele has
earned her spot uh here today Fox News
has a story quote Brazilian supermodel
Gisele Bundchen is breaking her Silence
about their divorce from former NFL
superstar Tom Brady after 13 years of
marriage bunch and spoke her truth in a
tell-all interview and put a stop to the
rumors for good
okay and second thought we have to make
a late addition to the cancellation
whoever wrote this article for Fox is
also canceled because I understand that
this article about a Gisele Bundchen
interview is not meant to be a classic
of American writing I realize it's just
content it's just fodder intended to be
vaguely consumed and then forgotten
about five seconds later but
as someone who was also in the business
of creating internet content can we have
at least a little bit of self-respect
and pride in our craft I mean you packed
three cliches into the first two
sentences breaking her silence spoke her
truth put a stop to the rumors for good
all I'm asking is that you take an
additional 45 seconds to think of a
slightly different way of wording it you
don't have to reach immediately for the
cliche clearance bin and this is
important for everyone on the internet
in the internet content creation space
to understand because they've already
created AI that can write articles
better than this so if you want to have
any chance of surviving you need to be
at least slightly more creative and
interesting and human than a chatbot
but anyway that's neither here nor there
back to the article it says the 42 year
old model said the split was the death
of my dream as she lost who was meant to
be her partner for life
she lost him oh she lost him did she did
you what did she let go of his hand at
the mall did he wander off in the middle
of the night lost him
no she didn't she didn't lose him like
you lose a pair you know a pair of shoes
she chose to leave him as an active
decision I'm not sure to what extent it
was a mutual decision maybe it was maybe
it wasn't but it's certain at least that
she was an active participant in the
divorce she didn't lose anything she
gave up they gave up
but don't tell her that she likes to uh
tell herself that this has all happened
on its own through forces
outside of her control
quote it's tough because you imagine
your life was going to be a certain way
and you did everything you could you
know bunching emotion emotionally told
Vanity Fair as you wiped away tears I
believed in fairy tales when I was a kid
I think it's beautiful to believe in
that I'm so grateful I did
a bunch and candidly addressed the
reason the former power a couple uh
decided to split uh after over a decade
together sometimes you grow together
sometimes you grow apart you know it
when I was 26 years old and he was 29
years old we met we wanted a family we
wanted things together as time goes by
we realized that we just wanted
different things and now we have to make
a choice
that doesn't mean you don't love this
person it just means that in order for
you to be authentic and truly live that
life that you want to live you have to
have someone who can meet you in the
middle right it's a dance it's a balance
when you love someone you set them free
to be who they are and if you want to
fly in the same direction then that's
amazing
okay let's clear up two things
first if you leave your spouse
it absolutely does mean that you don't
love him the word love has no meaning if
it can apply to a Broken Vow just as
much as it applies to an honored vowel
the way that Gisele defines love the way
that our culture defines It generally is
essentially like this a loving action is
whatever action I happen to be taking at
this moment
to love someone is to do whatever I want
to do
and this is what she means when she says
the word love
it's quite a convenient definition of
the term but it's also meaningless it's
a meaningless definition
love is not merely a feeling and even if
it was merely a feeling you clearly
don't feel too great about somebody if
you want to divorce them but it's more
than that love is a choice it's an act
it's a it's a sacrifice
um
love is an activity you know to love
your spouse is is to be faithful it is
to be loyal it is to be reliable it is
to look out for their physical and
spiritual well-being and so on divorce
is the severing of all of that which is
to say that it is the death of marital
love I mean that's the whole point of
getting divorced
the most important point is that
um a faithful marriage
and a divorce are both choices they are
they are options actively chosen
Giselle talks about marriage using
passive language we grow apart time goes
by sometimes you end up and you know you
end up going in different directions
it's like Tom and Gisele were two pieces
of litter you know a couple of empty
plastic bottles floating in a puddle
randomly bumping into each other and
then drifting off in opposite directions
she talks about like she has no control
over it now in any other situation she
is certain to speak highly and
confidently of her own her own agency
her strength as a Fierce and independent
woman but when it comes to making
excuses for a failed marriage
suddenly she's a helpless flower being
swept Along by the forces of fate
second uh Giselle claims that her
divorce was a necessary step in the
pursuit of authenticity
she says that in order to be authentic
and to live the life you want to live
sometimes you have to break your
marriage vows and destroy your family
and this is the part that really grates
me the most and why we're talking about
it because we hear a lot about
authenticity these days
and it's always in this context to be
authentic is to be selfish
the authentic path is the most
convenient path
it is authentic to the self in the sense
that it serves the interests of the self
or at least what you perceive your
interests to be
authenticity
not in any meaningful way
if it is authentic it's only because you
are authentically authentically
following your most cowardly and
self-serving and shallowest impulses
but there is a higher authenticity right
there is an authenticity that we should
actually strive towards
and that is the authentic authenticity
of a virtuous life the authenticity of
faithfulness and love and sacrifice
the authenticity of Promises Kept and
vows upheld
true authenticity can be found in the
pursuit of something greater than
yourself
which is what marriage is all about
or what it's supposed to be
and that's what Giselle has abandoned
and that's why she is today finally
canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
shows and move over to the members block
you become a member today use code walls
to check out for two months free on all
annual plans hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]